hey IMAX movie fans I am thrilled to  share with you this special look at  ghost in the shell see the movie this  March like it's meant to be seen on the  big screen ocean the shell is based on  the famous anime by the same title  [Music]  rupert sanders is really a visionary  director he's got a very strong guy the  anime to me has a certain feeling to see  that world imagined is pretty  spectacular Rupert has completely  created dommage to the manga and anime  for the fans it's really been all  encompassing empowering and about us to  bring this animated life there are many  challenges we can move from an animate  them into live action  that's something that Rupert and has  designed him spent months designing I  hope the audience shared the passion  that I have for this  I hope they wear when we go on this ride  with me  [Music]  you